welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA your grogu channel
when it comes to trailer breakdowns and
crap puns and to be fair I'm probably
not even your go-to channel anyway but
you're here now so let's get into the
Mandalorian season 3 trailer throughout
this video we'll be going over what
happens in it the Easter eggs and also
the general plot of what we think season
three is gonna be please hit the Thumbs
Up Button if you enjoy the video and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day by the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into the
trailer
foreign
okay so this looks like it's going to be
the biggest season of the show yet with
us getting expansive battles both on
land and in Space the teaser has a ton
of Mandalore in it which I want to
discuss in this video there's a large
number of locations in the trailer as
well and though we don't know what
exactly all these mystery planets are we
can guess at some and the teaser built
off the stuff that took focus in the
book of Boba Fett the last time we saw
the character he ended up going to the
armor and pre Vizsla on an elysium-like
space station now after being unable to
properly wield the darksaber he was told
that he must become one with the blade
the teaser tells us that Redemption is
no longer possible due to the
destruction of Mandalore so this might
be a case of them rebuilding things in
order to gain back that honor from here
he then traveled to the best deep fake
I've ever seen before journeying to
Tatooine where he got his new ship
Mandel was reunited with grogu and the
pair return now one thing you might
notice about his N1 Starfighter is that
it now has an Astromech droid in it this
looks like it's R5 who's given over by
Pali motto and in case you don't know
who this character is he ties all the
way back to a new hope this was the
drive that had the bust up motivator and
it allowed R2D2 to go on and live with
Luke Skywalker we all know what happened
there and yeah this Droid he's making
history again also due to the size of it
I'm guessing he's not really going to be
going after bounties because he wouldn't
be able to carry them due to the cargo
hold therefore I think this season will
very much be focused on the war for
Mandalore as well as those attempting to
get rid of it but Katan originally
sought out to be the ruler of the planet
but man no getting the dark saber threw
a spanner in the works the person who
possesses it is seen as the rightful
ruler and he seems far more hostile in
this entry
[Music]
this is the one that you saved
you are as its father
a clan
[Music]
of two we catch you with her helmet off
and she's also sitting on what appears
to be a throne whether she has no right
to rule and therefore I think that she's
gonna be an antagonist in the show she's
a major fan favorite too and a clever
thing that you'll notice in shows like
the boys and House of the Dragon is that
they make opposing sides filled with
characters that you're reading oh makes
the conflict far more engaging when you
don't know who you want to win and
obviously she'd make a great villain if
that's indeed the case the dark saber is
a play that has to be won in combat and
therefore the only way she can fulfill
her perceived Destiny is by taking it by
force and we see the city of sundari
showing that we are definitely traveling
to Mandalore this has of course been
destroyed but we can see the Dome shape
of it we also see kawaki and monkey
lizards who you'll likely recognize as
being the same species as salacious
bcrom I say that but but you might not
but come on mate you've seen Return of
the Jedi you have haven't you now huge
it adds to eckhart's ladder for pointing
out that this is likely Navarro as it
ties into the next shot of grip cargo we
also see the ig11 statue and this was
placed there in the courtyard after the
character's death now in addition to a
villain in bulkatan you also get the
return of Dr Pershing he was of course
working on cloning the midichlorians and
it's possible that this is tied into how
Palpatine returned because somehow
somehow Palpatine returned Kobe riffing
on Operation Paperclip in which the West
took German scientists and ordered a
bolster their own operations it seems
far more welcoming due to the
environment and him not being in Chains
this base could also be where moth
Gideon is at and it might be an escape
attempt now it seems that there's a gang
showing up to give grief grief and
you'll likely have to face up against
them we even see Mandel along with his
own Clan and there might even be one
wearing Mando's old chess piece
potentially took his old armor and I
can't see the sides being split in two
as they battle it out amongst themselves
whilst also trying to take back
Mandalore I actually think that they
might take back the planet early on in
the series and then it'll be a case of
everyone fighting it out for the rule of
it the belgaum and Throne thing might
even be after they've won and people
start dissenting because she doesn't
wield the darksaber now shout out to
eckhart's ladder again for showing that
we have ships that look similar to our
41 star chases slightly different design
and potentially they belong to the
underworld and criminal factions we get
a couple of space scenes with them
seemingly chasing after the N1 start
fighter makes me think that they could
be going after Kroger again as I think
the Bounty may still be on his head but
I'm not 100 on that these might be who
faced up against grief or they could be
hired by the remnants of the Empire
since they're running low on soldiers
next we have what I believe is the
Mandalorian Gauntlet ship and bogatan
appears to be flying this you also get
what appears to be Babu Frick or at
least his species these are anzelans and
they all seem to be mechanics which it's
it's a bit of a stereotype that mate
next we have a big scene with fireworks
and it may be possible that this is the
celebration after they take back
Mandalore again I'm basing that on the
fact that they take it back and then
there's a Civil War and it's all just
one big Theory and not confirmed just me
guessing but yeah that's where it seems
to be going that's most of the major
shots in the trailer and to me the most
important one is the trip to sandari it
might not even be occupied by the Empire
as the planet is a bit of a show at this
point and my guess is that they arrive
there to find it abandoned the quests
will then likely begin for who should be
the right bull ruler and I can't see the
season evolving up into that there's a
ton of directions they could take things
and though I may be reading this
completely wrong I do think that is
where things are gonna go I do however
feel like there's gonna be a lot of
things split down the middle on it with
fans very much going back and forth
every week on who they want to see in
charge Boca Town coming back was
obviously a big part of the last
Mandalorian season I know fans were over
the moon to see her return so I think
they can really play with that and have
her become even more of an anti-hero
where you don't know who to root for
but you have removed your helmet
then you are a Mandalorian
no more
[Music]
you're cult
fractured our people
where are you then
[Music]
did you think your dad was the only
Mandalorian
the budget on this looks really big too
will it seem like there's going to be
lots of different locations and there's
also more of a major cast whereas the
last entries had a more focused one I'm
expecting a lot of different people to
show up here and it's a really nice
trailer that gets me excited for what's
to come obviously I know there's going
to be lots of things to talk about and
probably things I missed so if you
spotted anything I didn't then make sure
you leave it in the comments below go on
accept that challenge make me look
stupid now we are in a competition right
now and giving away three copies of top
gun Maverick on the 15th of September
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the teaser we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch them make sure you check out our
breaking of She-Hulk which will be
linked on screen right now we went over
the whole show all the Easter eggs in it
and it's definitely worth checking out
right after this now the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see in the next one take care
peace